>> BONUS ROUND OF QUESTIONS
THERE.
NO ONE TOUGHER THAN THIS
PRESIDENT, ACCORDING TO HIM, ON
RUSSIA.
THINGS THAT STUCK OUT IN THIS
NEWS CONFERENCE DOWN THERE.
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE NOMINEE,
MIKE POMPEO.
IT'S SAYING IT WAS A GOOD TRIP
AND ABOUT THE CONDITIONS ARE SET
FOR HIS MEETING.
THE PRESIDENTS MEETING WITH
KIM JONG-UN.
ALSO SAYING THAT THEY ARE
WORKING ON GETTING THE AMERICANS
I NORTH KOREA IS HOLDING TO BE
RELEASED.
AND THERE IS PROGRESS.
ALSO, THAT THERE WILL BE A
BILATERAL TRADE TALKS AND
NEGOTIATIONS AND RECIPROCAL
TRADE DEALS WITH JAPAN.
AND THEN, FINALLY, ASKING ABOUT
THE MUELLER PROBE AND WHETHER HE
IS GOING TO A FIRE MUELLER OR
ROSENSTEIN, THE PRESIDENT SAYING
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ASSAYING
THESE TWO GENTLEMEN FOR THREE,
FOUR, FIVE MONTHS THAT THEY
ARE STILL HERE.
I WANT THIS OVER, ESSENTIALLY.
LET'S BRING BACK THE PANEL.
JONATHAN, WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT JAPAN IS GOING
TO TRY TO REDUCE THE DEFICIT BY
BUYING LOTS OF AMERICAN WEAPONS.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THEIR STRATEGY
TO REDUCE THE TRADE DEFICIT
WHICH IS THE MAJOR METRIC THAT
TRUMP IS CONCERNED ABOUT.
IT IS ALSO CLEAR THAT JAPAN IS
QUITE CONCERNED ABOUT THE U.S.
GIVING TOO MUCH OR TOO LITTLE.
YOU SAW IT WITH SAYING THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP UP THE CAMPAIGN ON
NORTH KOREA.
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY DO CONCRETE
THINGS TO DENUCLEARIZE.
SO YOU DO SEE SOME OF THAT'S
COMING THROUGH.
THEY HAVE A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP.
THE TWO HAVE A CLOSE PERSONAL
REPORT.
AND TRADE IS ONE OF THE BIG
ISSUES THAT TRUMP AT --
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THIS TWEET
EARLIER?
>> YEAH, IT WAS INTERESTING.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE PEOPLE AND
THE NEED TO GET THEM BACK.
HOW MUCH THEY AGREE ON THINGS
LIKE THE ABDUCTED JAPANESE.
ALSO THAT THEY ARE OF THE SHARED
MIND-SET AGAINST NORTH KOREA.
NORTH KOREA HAS PREVIOUSLY SAID
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
DENUCLEARIZE.
ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE GOTTEN THEM
TO SAY THAT, BUT IT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
THAT'S WHY IT IS VERY IMPORTANT,
AND I THINK SHINZO ABE WAS VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
AND THEY ARE UNIFIED IN THAT
APPROACH.
>> Bret: WHAT I TALKED WITH A
SHINZO ABE IN JAPAN.
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR THAT HE
MENTIONED IN THIS NEWS
CONFERENCE HE ALSO MENTIONED TO
ME.
>> NORTH KOREA HAS USED OF THOSE
TALKS JUST TO GAIN TIME TO
FURTHER DEVELOP THEIR NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
SO NORTH KOREAN DIALOGUE IT JUST
FOR THE PURPOSE OF DIALOGUE IS
MEANINGLESS.
THAT IS THEIR EXPERIENCE.
THESE ARE YEAH, HE EMPHASIZED
THAT.
THEY ARE SOMEWHAT HOPEFUL.
>> RIGHT.
YOU MENTIONED HE WAS THE FIRST
TO MEET WITH PRESIDENT-ELECT A
DONALD TRUMP IN THE TRANSITION
BECAUSE HE WAS SO AFRAID OF THE